if you look on storage let me make this
perfectly clear if we do not implement
the program we have created the measures
we recommend Moscow and which the German
government has also adopted for reading
tone if we do not manage to reduce
contact between people for a few weeks
then it is possible that in two to three
months we will have up to 10 million
infected people in Germany this will be
a considerable burden on our health
system reasons our chief political
correspondent Linda crane is covering
the story Melinda our people in Germany
largely following the measures
prescribed by the government it's a very
mixed picture on the one hand 80% of
Germans say that they find the measures
correct and that they think they're
necessary and officially many many
measures have been followed for example
schools are shut most bars and
restaurants are either closed or largely
empty large events are being canceled
months into the future but informally
the picture is pretty different I just
came here on my bicycle through
beautiful sunny parks and streets and
there were a lot of people out who were
definitely not following social
distancing precautions nearly 25 men
watching and/or playing soccer for
example spontaneously on a soccer pitch
groups of people sitting in the Sun
chatting all of those are potential
infection chains and when we also look
at the surveys of people here in Germany
many younger people in the 20 to 29 year
old age bracket say they're not taking
it quite so seriously now the fact is
those young people probably wouldn't get
very ill if they caught kovat but they
are super carriers as it's known that
means they can infect a lot of very much
more vulnerable people so they need to
be following these measures and if
they're not we may see stricter measures
put in place that is what I wanted to
ask you there's a lot of anxiety many
people are wondering whether the German
government will impose a lockdown the
way that is already in place in Italy
Spain
France are there any indications that
the German government will take that
step
it's certainly not impossible I don't
think we're going to hear the Chancellor
say that this evening she is going to be
speaking once again to the nation but
we're told it will be an appeal to
Germans trying to explain why the
measures are so important and why they
need to follow them but certainly in the
government's toolbox is is that complete
lockdown that Prevention on people
leaving their homes for anything but the
most urgent business they would probably
need to declare a national emergency to
do that but certainly other countries
have done it as you said Italy Spain
France so we may well see that happen
here
borders are already shutting down around
Germany Germany has nine direct
neighbors what impact are those border
shutdowns having well amongst the impact
is that Germany has just announced as
you said briefly at the top of the show
that it will not be taking in any more
refugees or applicate applicants for
refugee status in its Syrian
resettlement program now the Chancellor
did speak yesterday to the leaders of
Britain France and Turkey about this
very matter turkey certainly would then
face a much bigger burden in terms of
the large numbers of people leaving
Syria for Turkey the Chancellor has said
she would be willing to see Turkey given
more financial support to handle that
burden but that's just one of many many
consequences that we are seeing a fast
moving story Melinda thanks for bringing
us update that is our chief political
correspondent Melinda Crain let's get an
update on the latest we know about the
corona virus we are starting to
understand more about it a new study is
confirmed previous estimates that the
median incubation period for the virus
is five days patients are most
contagious just before they start
showing symptoms and in the first week
of symptoms the virus cannot be spread
by patients stool that's good news for
caregivers and hospital workers
authorities caution that the drastic
measures taken worldwide to try and
contain the spread of the virus could be
extended and last four months our
science correspondent Derek Williams has
been tracking these developments all
along Derek this new study out of
Australia it's providing some insights
into how the body reacts to kovat 19
what have we learned from it well the
study which was published a day or two
ago in Nature Medicine which is either
respected scientific journal basically
focused on a single patient who
contracted Kovac 19:00 and gohan but
only fell ill with it when she was in
Australia now the researchers said her
case was mild to moderate so she but she
was hospitalized but she didn't receive
any drugs and she didn't have to be put
on a ventilator so despite her
hospitalization she had a really a less
severe form of the disease what was new
and important about her was that the
team of scientists that was able to
study her immune response to the virus
and in detail for example through blood
samples that that closely tracked when
she began to develop antibodies against
the disease and whether they continue to
be present after the infection ran its
course
so it was it also told them at least in
this otherwise healthy patient which
kind of immune cells appear and when so
they were able to describe the woman's
entire immune response in pretty great
detail okay this is just one particular
case though how will information like
this help us fight the disease well
knowing how immune responses work and
when when certain processes activate
during an infection in a healthy
patients body is important for several
different reasons first because having
when I say healthy patient I mean a
patient who going into the infection was
a relatively healthy individual first
because having that information
potentially allows us to develop tests
that will let us track the progress of
the disease in patients more or less in
real-time
see if that information can be vital in
terms of making decisions about when to
do what
in the course of the infection so the
data can also in the long term help us
with vaccine developments it could
provide some clues
as to how and to why some people react
to the virus more seriously for example
than than others and last but not least
could help us understand exactly why the
immune response er is weaker in some
patients of course a lot of studies of
the corona virus are currently underway
what else have we learned so far well
another very interesting study published
recently that came from researchers here
in in Germany was aimed at addressing a
few other vital points for example it
provided much more precise data on
exactly when patients are most
contagious the researchers eventually
tracked viral activity and and the
virus's ability to replicate over time
and in different parts of the body and
they looked closely at how the disease
might be passed along studying viral
loads and in a group of patients that
that over time in a wide range of
potentially infectious material like
from mucus and blood to to urine and and
to stool and there's findings suggest
that people are most contagious before
they have the disease they also
discovered that the virus reproduces and
absolutely huge amounts and their
patients they found up to a thousand
times more of it in some cases that were
usually found in patients infected with
other related pathogens like like the
SARS virus that might explain why the
new virus is also so infectious finally
as we heard just a while ago they were
able to to find they found viral genetic
material in stool but they also were
able to determine that it wasn't active
so that's good news for then will have
ramifications for medical staff and for
and for caregivers as we move forward
and more and more people are infected so
fundamental research is moving forward
to cont research really that in the long
run is going it's going to help save
lives
good to hear Derek our science
correspondent Derek Williams as I
mentioned earlier much of Europe is in
lockdown but EU countries aren't the
only ones hunkering down the US and
Canada which share the world's longest
land border are working out the details
of banning all non-essential travel
between the two countries British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson has
that the UK might also have to close its
schools as is already the case in many
other European countries the Czech
government is ordering its citizens to
start wearing face masks or something
else to cover their mouths and noses
when they go out in public and Japan's
deputy prime minister says holding the
Summer Olympics would make no sense if
countries can't send athletes but the
government says it's still working to
hold the games as scheduled
well doctors nurses are at the forefront
of efforts to save lives in Europe's
worst affected country Italy more than
two and a half thousand health workers
have tested positive for the corona
virus the northern region of Lombardy
which has been at the center of the
outbreak is appealing to recently
retired doctors and nurses to return to
work to help overwhelm colleagues we
take you now inside an intensive care
unit in Italy the camera follows calamus
trainee into the epicenter of the corona
virus crisis in northern Italy a
hospital in Cremona in the Lombardy
region she explains what she must wear
to keep safe surgical gloves shoe covers
headgear special gloves that are
different to the ones I've got on now
and most importantly face masks and
protective glasses most Rini and her
colleagues have lost count of the number
of hours they've spent treating patients
in the intensive care unit patients are
connected to ventilators while lying on
their stomachs the pressure makes it
easier for oxygen to enter the blood
stream at least that's what's supposed
to happen for people suffering from
pneumonia but now the method isn't
working and the doctors and nurses can't
explain why
unfortunately we haven't seen anyone
recover yet in this hospital ideally
we'd like to take some patients off the
ventilators and see whether they get
better
we need a successful case to know that
we're doing the right things up until
now mastery knee says 107 patients have
already died in this unit of the
hospital out of 850 for people who were
brought here we've had several deaths
and it's really wearing us down because
we're thinking we're not in a position
to do what we're here for treating
patients so they get better we're
watching them die and inside we're dying
to the hospital in Cremona has been
taking in coronavirus patients since the
beginning of the outbreak outside
they've set up tents for triage sorting
patients for treatment what shocks me is
that we have no power in the face of
this emergency of course we're used to
dealing with severely ill patients who
are close to death and we know what our
job is but we've never had such a rapid
influx of people in danger of losing
their lives it's hard it's hard for
everyone the death rate is significant
but there has been one ray of light here
today a 23 year old man made a full
recovery and was able to leave the
hospital at night I collapse on the sofa
I sleep but not well because I'm waking
up every hour with nightmares my husband
and daughter wait at home for me they
try to talk to me but I don't really
take it in they ask me if I'm listening
but I can't
it's terrible columnist rainy will keep
trying to help and to heal that is her
job at the hospital in Cremona the
epicenter of the coronavirus crisis
we'll be looking at some of the economic
fallout from the coronavirus crisis in a
moment first let's catch up on a couple
of other stories former Vice President
Joe Biden has topped the poll in the
three latest Democratic presidential
primaries in the US the voting went
ahead in Arizona Florida and Illinois
despite fears about the spreading
coronavirus Ohio postponed its scheduled
primary due to the Fed having BMW is
shutting down all car production in
Europe and South Africa until at least
the end of April the German carmaker
said it needs to protect the health of
its employees the company already had at
least three identified cases of
coronavirus at its research and
development center in Munich
earlier this week Daimler and Volkswagen
also announced shutting down plants
while the airline industry could
collapse without significant help from
world governments that's the dire
message from the International Air
Transport Association a body that
represents the vast majority of global
air traffic well the IATA says companies
will need between 150 and 200 million
dollars to weather the pandemic and that
Kerry and the carriers are short of cash
to provide refunds especially hard-hit
are airlines that rely on the lucrative
transatlantic route last week US
President Donald Trump banned most
incoming flights from Europe for 30 days
and the US is imposing the EU rather is
imposing limitations to German
Chancellor Angela Merkel now says non EU
residents will not be allowed to enter
the block for the same period and it's
not just weakening demand that's hurting
the industry plane makers are cutting
production as a result of supply chain
disruption and employee absences in the
u.s. Boeing has
already asked the White House for
assistance and here in Europe airbus has
halted production in France and Spain
well christophe cover from our DW
business team joins us now from Hannover
Christophe airlines are in freefall how
are they coping with this rather badly
tere several carriers have now halted
their operations altogether Lufthansa
subsidiary Brussels Airlines in Austrian
here in Europe for example Egypt air
also halting operations and industry
experts are saying there'll be more
there'll be more to come
when we when we look at these
cancellations and and stopping of
operations altogether a growing number
of governments is now rushing towards
the the airline industry in order to
help them there's talk about financial
aid financial help Australia being one
of the most recent countries to provide
financial aid to the sector EU transport
ministers are talking about tax relief
for the aviation industry and in the
United States sector executives are due
to speak with President Trump about the
matter today now airline executives not
surprising they're saying that this is
the worst crisis to hit their industry
ever worse even than 9/11 tell us what
is it that makes this situation so
exceptional well because the
countermeasures to fight the pandemic
they are laying hand to the very root of
the aviation industries business model
if you are told to stay at home if
you're told to distance yourself if
countries seal off their borders and if
there's a persistent fear that
intercontinental travel will contribute
to the spread of the virus all of that
is a direct blow to everything that the
aviation industry stands for and if we
talk about the 9/11 terror attacks after
those heightened restrictions and and
security
were put into place all of which we've
come to terms with these days but these
moves these sort of measures they don't
work in this case and then there's the
time frame again if we look at the 911
attacks the the heightened security
measures were implemented fairly quickly
after that and took effect fairly
quickly after that whereas here the
virus could be spreading for months
possibly even longer and the airline
might have to deal with the consequences
for that amount of time which is an
incredible burden for the industry
speaking of consequences what options do
the airlines have then Christoph they'll
be going out going some will go out of
business one thing that is the fear and
that's what what industry experts expect
I mean there are there's a number of
options none of which are desirable I
mean we see some of those the grounding
of the fleet the cutting of flights you
know
severely limiting the service also
putting staff on reduced work on reduced
pay cutting jobs as KLM and and British
Airways have announced there is another
way to address this crisis here by
amending the terms and conditions of
bookings for example letting passengers
allow you know letting them book with
more confidence in the fact and the
sense that passengers are allowed to
just change their their route of travel
up to the very last day on very short
notice without having to pay anything
for it and of course there's the cry for
government help we talk about tax relief
we talk about the relief of fees and
obviously direct financial help all of
it is being discussed right now some of
which has been granted
christop thank you very much that was
our business correspondent Christophe
Cobra